In this section of our course, we will go over metahuman tools and workflows that can be used to achieve more likeness with our metahuman character.
We will also go through a hands-on session for creating a metahuman in Engine using the metahuman plugin for Unreal Engine with a face scan asset created using the RealityScan mobile app.
The metahuman plugin allows you to create a metahuman from a 3D character mesh and is available from Engine versions 5.0 or later.
You can also create a metahuman from facial footage with Engine versions 5.2 or later.
To use the plugin, begin by installing the metahuman plugin to the appropriate Engine version from the fab marketplace.
Once the plugin is installed, inside of your Unreal Engine project, open up the plugin's menu, enable the metahuman plugin, and then restart the Engine.
This plugin is already installed and enabled in our course project.
For our hands-on exercise, we will be using a face scan that was captured using the RealityScan mobile app.
RealityCapture is a company that is part of Epic Games, and you can use the standalone or mobile app version for free by signing in with your Epic Games account.
If using the RealityScan mobile app, once you capture your scanned data, that data will be processed in the mobile app, and from there you can either export the 3D model or share it on Sketchfab.
Once you have the asset, inspect it, and then import it into Unreal Engine.
Using the face scan data that has been captured with the RealityScan mobile app, let's dive into a hands-on exercise and create a metahuman in Unreal Engine.